hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to ragdoll runners now I
don't know much about this game but
looking at it it looks a lot like co-op
I don't know if it's gonna be exactly
like [ __ ] but I do know for a fact that
I'm bad at co-op so I know I'm gonna be
bad at this too but you know in all
fairness I don't want to unleash my
skill and too big of a burst so I'm
gonna just take the tutorial - oh god no
it is qwop oh it's so QWOP han ah oh oh
it's elegant
wait this isn't right then release the
key huh ah ah okay e or e or e or e OE
OE OE OE OE oh oh oh oh I don't know if
I'm gonna be able to do who that I don't
know if I'm gonna be able to do that or
any of that in whatever way I'm not
gonna be able to do that oh my god you
can play against people oh why did
anybody tell me about this I didn't know
about this oh my god oh I'm not gonna
win yeah yeah oh God ah he'll never beat
me you'll never beat me
oh [ __ ] oh god damn it ha oh god yeah
yeah oh did I do it yeah celebration
maybe man that was a lot more
challenging than I thought I'd be ok
let's analyze the replay oh you see
there I was a little cool enough to go
and I had a daisy chain
Natalie Duke start I didn't do nothing
for me alright so uh let's try let's try
a lot of the events first
aha
ah why am i jump I'm jumping why am i
I'm jumping hi that that's that's not
the way that this is supposed to go ah
come on don't jump stop you been huh
tuck and roll did I do it I did it
I don't know how I did it but I did it
okay okay
yeah all right I skipped a level because
I was so good at it oh man this never
happens to me
usually when I walk in a room people
shun and get angry and then start
beating me and then insulting me take my
lunch money all right 60 meters oh oh
we're on oh oh I wasn't even saying
anything I was concentrating Zord yeah
okay we got a here oh [ __ ] oh no no no
he's a leaping bunny of majestic
proportions ah [ __ ] I got out of rhythm
god damn it that tutorial didn't teach
me dick yeah oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] ah come on
yeah yeah yeah yeah gooo giggle uh [ __ ]
balls and ass tits yeah no I don't want
to see the replay yes oh god damn it
this is worse than before
oh I hate this oh I hate this Oh every
part of me hates this what do you mean
boo doing the best I can I don't
understand how anyone would be good at
this
oh I did better than my personal best
though but not yet there's always room
for improvement
yeah yeah god damn it I can't loop back
the bar
walk again yeah I did
okay okay okay okay okay
no don't jump don't jump stop me you've
been oh god no I swear hey hey ah yeah
yeah yeah don't you don't you yeah I did
it yeah I did it I'm a winner
yeah I feel good I don't feel good I
don't feel good at all feel like sick to
my stomach oh man
whoa we did it I don't want to do the
hundred meter how in the hell might have
been to be able to do the hundred meter
oh boy all right here we go
yeah come on come on get some traction
damn it get some goddamn traction here
we go here we go here we go here we go
whoa there we go ha ha ha ha ha well
there we go there we go don't young stop
young Ben stop young Ben you [ __ ] ah
there we go
get the scoop action whoa get the scoop
action whoo get the scoop in oh my god
I'm actually doing something whoa look
at me go holy [ __ ] ah [ __ ] I [ __ ] it
up I [ __ ] it I got cocky and I [ __ ]
it I [ __ ] it all up
hey hey hey daddy buddy there we go okay
goddamn it I did good and first and then
I did terribly we did it though
and that's all that matters there's no
way in hell I'd be able to get the world
record of eight point eight five seconds
that's faster than it's faster than
anyone can do whoo yeah you stopped
celebrating over there you didn't do
jack dick hi now the long jump oh god
why I'm not gonna be able to do that I
don't even know how to jump okay here we
go
here yeah okay yeah
oh Jesus oh oh oh come on
I don't even know how to jump oh no I
broke my ass I got an achievement for
breaking my ass bone [ __ ]
alright whatever wait what am I do what
what is this
alright you know what I need as much
speed as I can so I'm not gonna get much
whoa whoa holy [ __ ] look at me go Wi-Fi
[ __ ] dirt yes oh I tried to tuck in did
I do it yeah I don't know how I did it
but out of it okay it's pretty dang good
look at me go all in slow motion like
right on the step I did wonderfully if
only I had tucked my feet in I would
have done a lot better
whoa number four the triple jump I can
barely jump once how am I gonna be able
to triple jump yeah yeah no that's not
the right way to go about that's not the
right way there hey oh [ __ ] y'all [ __ ]
up guy yeah [ __ ] you [ __ ] it up I did
a front flip
[ __ ] that [ __ ] god dammit thought about
stop humping my face [ __ ] time with
less douche I've got a lot of douche
stored up in my grundle one two three ah
goddamn it
I mean it's it's okay but I feel like I
I did a single long jump almost as good
as that okay Myrtle's hurdles hurdles oh
boy
oh boy oh boy yeah ah goddamnit I [ __ ]
it up [ __ ] [ __ ] ah
why [ __ ] [ __ ] why can't I get any
goddamn momentum again what is this
oh my god it's fast though holy [ __ ]
that was fast
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I found that
digger technique
it's like Naruto running except I do
with my face first yeah yeah here yeah
no no no no yo yo yo yo yo you're on
your Oh nope yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah - yeah cat what sucked no all
right let's try it again
okay so far so goo I mean not do [ __ ]
[ __ ] I [ __ ] it I [ __ ] that I [ __ ]
that I [ __ ] that I [ __ ] it I'm not
gonna [ __ ] it anymore
yep whoop good oh [ __ ] oh god damn it
come on stop going up in the air and
[ __ ] go forward you [ __ ] [ __ ] what
the I I don't understand how I suddenly
can't [ __ ] run what the [ __ ] is going
on
just [ __ ] go what the [ __ ] what the
fack
what's a [ __ ] that's how I [ __ ] over do
what da [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm sorry I lost my cool little bit
there that was the most frustrating
thing I've ever done in my entire life I
am not exaggerating that was literally
the most frustrating thing I've ever
seen in my life and here I go again
yeah come on come on
Oh [ __ ] come on oh my god oh my god
yeah that was something that was
something that resembled not sucking ass
God you almost made it huh
but you didn't quite make it cuz the
entire first half of the goddamn race
you were too busy sucking everyone
else's dick oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god I
[ __ ] hate this
god damnit holy [ __ ] what uh how am i
doing worse every time I'm doing
literally worse every time I go after
this thing I'm doing worse what the [ __ ]
oh my god
no you were off to such a good start I
can't take this I can't do it uh there's
not an exaggeration
I'm not [ __ ] do anything holy [ __ ] I
can't [ __ ] take this I literally
cannot [ __ ] take this this is
ridiculous
oh my god are you kidding me why why why
I don't get why why why oh my god oh I
[ __ ] kick Oh Mike you're Ida
[Applause]
Oh
teach me again what the [ __ ] do you do
uh oh no no no no no no no no [ __ ] it no
[ __ ] you no I'm done I'm [ __ ] game
I'm done I know I will not I was having
a good time I was having a good [ __ ]
time I was having a great time playing
the game and then you throw that
[ __ ] at me I am [ __ ] done you
guys don't get it it's infuriating
what's the number-one thing I hate bad
controls I [ __ ] hate that
good god oh I don't have the patience to
be good at you so anyway we're all done
here I just screamed my entire voice out
I didn't want to do that because I
wanted to record more but I guess I'm
done because every once in a while
the burning hatred in my soul manifests
itself as a game and it's this [ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] his game [ __ ] this game
actually specifically [ __ ] the hurdles
everything else was fine up until then I
was having a fine time [ __ ] the hurdles
okay I'm gonna go relax I'm gonna rest
I'm gonna take it easy I'm never gonna
play this game ever ever ever again so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye